– Frau Brunner, vielen Dank für Ihre Hilfe!
– Gern.
Ich finde, dass Selma
erstaunliche Fortschritte macht.
– Sie ist intelligent.
Wir sind sehr stolz auf sie.
– Was ist eigentlich mit Ihnen?
– Mit mir?
– Ja. Sie haben doch einen neuen Job.
Gefällt Ihnen die Arbeit?
– Ach so.
Na ja.
Der Unterschied zu meiner Arbeit
als Arzt ist sehr groß.
Aber ich habe Arbeit.
Und das ist am wichtigsten.
– Wissen Sie denn schon,
wann Ihre Sprachprüfung ist?
Die ist schon bald, oder?
– Ja.
In ein paar Wochen.
Das Datum aber hab ich jetzt nicht im Kopf.
– Ja, das ist ja auch nicht so wichtig.
Sind Sie denn gut vorbereitet?
– Na ja.
Ich habe nur wenig Zeit zum Lernen
und ich kenne auch nicht viele Deutsche.
Ich spreche die Sprache viel zu selten.
Ich kann wirklich nicht sagen,
ob ich es schaffe.
Aber ich hoffe es.
– Ach Sie sprechen doch schon
sehr gut Deutsch!
Herr Al-Pascha,
ich möchte wissen, ob es möglich ist,
dass wir Selmas Sprachunterricht
ab jetzt wieder bei mir machen.
– Es tut mir sehr leid,
aber das ist nicht möglich.
Selma hat uns angelogen.
Wir können ihr nicht mehr vertrauen.
– Ja, ich meine nur …
Gibt es nicht irgendeine Lösung?
Hier geht es um Selmas Zukunft.
– Das ist Sache der Familie.
– Okay.